Let's discuss
the social rights
of the sister in Islam.
Allah says in the Quran
in surah number 9 verse number 71
the believing men and women
they are
sisters unto one another. They are
protectors. All yabad all means they are
protectors or supporters. In Islamic
terminology you can say that they should
support each other or should be sisters
unto one another unless otherwise.
And the prophet referred to the woman as
shakat meaning one half. The other
meaning of shakat is sister.
So in Islam the women are one half and
their sister to one another unless
otherwise.
Let's discuss
the educational rights of the woman
Islam.
The first guidance given by Allah
subhana wa ta'ala in the glorious Quran
to the whole of humankind was not to
pray,
was not to give zakat,
was not to fast. It was read, recite,
proclaim. And this commandment to read
was not given only to the men. It was
given to both men and women.
And our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said
it's had of ima had number two 204
is obligatory for every Muslim man or
woman to acquire knowledge.
Muslim. It is obligatory for every
Muslim, man or woman to knowledge, not
only the male but both man and woman
obligatory. And the prophet made it a
duty for the parents, they should
educate the children, especially the
women. And told the husband that if the
wife wants religious education which is
compulsory, he has to provide her.
It's her right and his duty that the
wife should be educated at least
religiously.
And when a group of women came to the
prophet mentioned Sai Bkari and
approached him and told that you have
always are surrounded by men why don't
you give us one particular day
for exclusively for us and the prophet
gave that day and he appointed Sahabas
to regularly go and educate the woman.
You have several examples. Imagine in
the days of Yahela, in the days of
ignorance, you have examples of women
who were scholars. The best example I
can think of is
Aisha Abu Bakr. May Allah be pleased
with her. She was the wife of the
prophet and daughter of the first calip
of Islam. Abu Bakr, may Allah be pleased
with her.
She
married the prophet at a very young age
and lived after the prophet died for
several years which was a source of
guidance not only for the Sabas even for
Hular Rashid.
One of her students by the name of Urva,
she said she has not seen a scholar
greater than Aisha
in the field
of
lawful and unlawful things
in the teaching of the Quran
in Arabic literature and poetry in
Arabic history and genealogy.
Many a times when the people from
different parts used to come to consult
with the prophet she used to hear and
memorize
that's the reason she was expert even in
medicine she was even expert in
mathematics that the reason many a time
the sabas came to consult her especially
in the matter of mirat that is
inheritance
according to mus alashshari who's a
famous jurist he says that many of the
sabas and they did not understand a
hadith. They used to always approach her
and she always had some knowledge which
would benefit the Sabas
and she alone
has narrated no less than 2,210
a hadit
and she alone has taught no less than 82
different scholars in short Aisha
Abuakar may Allah be pleased with her
She was a scholar of the scholars.